um also there is someone in the comments
that wants to know how do you get your
woman to keep fit is it disrespectful to
ask
um how do you get your woman to keep we
have a personal trainer that comes to
the house five days a week right but I
mean not everybody not everybody can
afford that here's the thing
um
no no man um if no no if you have to if
you have to how can I put this if you
have to tell your woman hey you're you
know packing on the pounds blah blah
blah blah now don't get me wrong like
Devin there have been times where
Devon's a little puffier than normal at
which point I take action but Devin's
never gotten fat she's never ever ever
gotten fat not on my goddamn watch I pay
way too much money for that but if if
you're with a woman who does not respect
you enough to take care of herself to
remain attractive to you this means
She's Not That Into You And if she's not
that into you there's either something
wrong with her something wrong with you
or both you can't ever you can't talk a
woman into being in into keeping herself
in shape she has to be motivated enough
on her own to stay in shape in order to
stay in order to stay to keep your
commitment here's another thing you want
to know how to keep your you want to
know how to get your woman to be fit is
number one you have to maintain your
value you don't have to be this quote
unquote height you have to you have to
have high value right this doesn't mean
you have to be a millionaire you have to
be a good uh Steward of your money
you've got to be an above average shape
you have to have red pill awareness you
have to know how to handle women today's
modern women as they come if but that
that's that of course that's those are
the prerequisites but your woman has to
know and understand that if she doesn't
uphold her end of the bargain and keep
herself fit that you can and will
replace her if need be women don't
respond to hey baby I would really know
women respond to you flirting with the
hot waitress they respond to other women
looking at you your woman knows when
other women are looking at you and when
other women and the only way to get
other women to look at you is to stay in
shape you know uh you know stay you know
stay fly dress nice smell nice Etc et
cetera if you keep yourself in good
shape then your woman is going to keep
your herself in good shape because she
sees how other women are looking at you
don't tell your woman well listen you
know I could Play Shoot nope show her
and and there might be and I don't I'm
not I don't look at the chat I've got
that I've got that all closed but there
might be people in the chat or the
comments well that's disrespectful call
it whatever you want that is what's
necessary in today's sexual and
relationship Marketplace your woman has
absolutely got to know that you can and
will replace her if she gets fat so the
way to keep your woman from the the way
to keep your woman from Gaining all that
weight in the first place is to make
sure that you keep your [ __ ] together
that's the best motivating factor
Donovan Donovan don't tell them that
that works
that doesn't work David right Devin
there's so many more listeners like well
it shouldn't work that way 100 listen
man
um there are um there are a lot of a lot
of my critics and detractors talk about
my quote-unquote methods right it
shouldn't work this way you shouldn't do
this to your woman this is immoral
they're blah blah I'm a hundred percent
in agreement with all of them but here's
the thing this is the world we live in
I'm not here talking about the way
things should be I'm here to talk about
the way things are women and the the
environment has changed the environment
has changed and so women have changed
with it if you want to have successful
if you want to be successful women in
2022 you have one of two options either
deal with them as they are or check out
of the of the dating Market all together
I'm not gonna be mad at you if you do
one or the other but wishing women were
back in the 1950s or bitching and
moaning about what's fair and what's not
you shouldn't have to do that no I
shouldn't have to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
to get respect from women but
unfortunately unfortunately that's
what's required so that's what we do men
we're solvers we saw the problem okay
women are hoes and they're no they're
little they're no longer exercising
hypergamy but ho pergamy and if you're
too nice to women they don't respect you
but if you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] they
respect you more so guess what we
adjusted and surprise surprise women are
complaining about it and then still
[ __ ] us so this is what it is men
need to stop acting like victims in
their own relationship for their lack of
leadership
um if your woman is getting overweight
um odds are she's bringing food into the
house that's not healthy
um and if she's bringing food into the
house it's not healthy she's buying it
with the household budget which means if
it's your home that's you that's under
your control
um there have been times where Donovan
has been like okay I want to review the
grocery order or the grocery list or
whatever before you submit it or before
you bring it into the house South he's
opened up the pantry and just thrown out
everything that he didn't want to have
in the house if it was something that
wasn't healthy
um there are there are ways that you can
express your uh not just what you want
but what your requirements
um and it's loud and clear to the woman
now if she's ignoring it if she's you
know just flat out different going
against your your requests
um then obviously there's there's a
deeper issue going on this relationship
that's further respective period yeah
that's what it is a lot of women will
try to hide their weight gain by trying
to fatten up their husbands as well so
if you're eating lasagna for dinner
three times a week that sounds wonderful
you know and she's she's baking and
she's baking chocolate cakes
and it's great oh yeah my wife cooks and
she you know she dinners on the table
but it's it's unhealthy and it's making
you guys sick
odds are she's going through something
you all need to sit down and figure it
out
um and you know there are ways gentle
ways that you can encourage your
significant other to work out as far as
hey let's go for a walk let's do this no
stop right there no no no no no no no no
no no I gotta cut you off no no no no no
this is bad advice that listen love you
to death sweetheart this is bad advice
listen man yeah it has to be established
from the start I never have to tell Dev
hey honey uh you want to go for a walk
no Devin's Devin's ass is in there
sweating her ass off five days a week
because she knows if she doesn't she's
she's the [ __ ] up out of here and the
reason why she knows she's the [ __ ] up
out of here is because of who and what I
am I'm not special I'm not unique I'm
just I'm I'm on yes I'm I've slept with
more I've slipping more women than the
average man yes I make far more than the
ever than than uh than the average man
and those are those those are the things
that sort of Encompass who I am but if
Devin didn't feel like it was worth it
then she would not do it there is no
reason at all for you to ever have to
tell your woman hey I'm going to get you
an exercise or gym membership by then
it's already too late if your woman does
not respect you enough to keep herself
in shape to maintain uh to maintain your
attraction to her it's over there is no
let's go for a walk there is no buying
her a Peloton for Christmas she's either
going to stay in shape of her own accord
or she's not period that's what I was
gonna say my butt was him telling you
directly is is going to be the most
effective that's right women women take
hints no women women not only can women
women can take hints they just choose to
ignore them they do they they choose to
ignore the hints and when it's funny
when Deb and I first got together
um it's interesting because Devin's
always had a really nice figure but
we're not getting any younger I tried to
get her to the gym and this and that and
the other so I said you know what I know
one thing Devin's not going to do she's
not going to waste my money I hired her
a personal trainer it's made all the
difference in the world yes it is very
costly it is very expensive it is also
very worth it I love it
well and what I realized is do you know
the more I like heard about the the
things you you specifically said on your
channel I realized you're giving men a
solution